[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen so salis welt
heute gibt's eine rote beete smoothie
aus nur wenigen zutaten wenn ihr rote
bete nicht so gerne mögt profiteams
moderne trotzdem aus es wirklich super
lecker
ich mache jetzt einmal als smoothie ich
habe auch schon handschuh wegen der
roten beete einmal als musi und einmal
als saft und sich jetzt auch einmal
entsaften und ich zeige euch dann auch
was ihr mit den resten machen könnt also
ich nehme jetzt für den smoothie eine
kleine rote beete so eine kleine knolle
zwei äpfel karotten etwas zitronensaft
und orangensaft und wasser
gut wäre es jetzt noch gewesen wenn ich
eiswürfel da hätte ich habe ich jetzt
leider nicht das wasser fließt einfach
solange ein damit ist auch schon eiskalt
ich nehme jetzt erstmal die orange die
kann ich hier nämlich filetieren
das heißt hier außen die schale
wegnehmen
[Musik]
und beim smoothie machen beim mix an
immer aufpassen und einfach die weichen
zutaten und dann erst die härteren
zutaten drüber die karotten muss ich
jetzt leider schälen denn die sind das
sind keine biografen sind zwar regionale
aber leider keine bio karotten bisschen
geschädigte jetzt
[Musik]
zitronensaft und jetzt kommt die schöne
rote beete du kannst gleich das wasser
dann rein kippen okay wir holen uns
gleich vor wie schön die rote beete ist
das wird gleich ein pink smoothie ja ja
aber da ist im kern etwas aufgehellt
cool wie schön dieses und da gebe ich
jetzt das eiskalte wasser drauf und mix
ist einmal durch und los ok und jetzt
wird gemixt
[Musik]
jetzt mit dem musik kaltgestellt und ich
zeige euch jetzt noch mal den gleichen
smoothie im prinzip aber als saft kinder
mögen ja oft nicht wenn man noch ein
bisschen was zwischen den zähnen hat
oder das ganze breiter ist ich trink
smoothies ganz gerne vor allem hat man
keine reste aber wir machen jetzt auch
einmal als saft und interesse daran
übrig bleibt dem benutze ich dann
einfach weiter ich habe jetzt hier nur
weil er es sich gewünscht hat noch
ananas mit dabei hier eine kleine süße
und kommen jetzt machen wir einfach dem
saft okay also
und weil es sonst logos are also ein
ganz langsamer saft und mich doch meine
handschuhe weg in der roten bete dass
man jetzt erst mal rein
das ist nicht so laut
[Musik]
so viel saft haben wir jetzt gewonnen
ich gebe es hier noch wasser rein da
kann ich noch so den rest raus spielen
perfekt ich geb dir noch was
und jeder hat aber lecker
ich finde rote beete saft mega und die
reste die ich jetzt hier habe die könnt
ihr zum beispiel in brotteig ein kneten
ins magische paket mit reinen kneten ihr
könnt kuchen daraus machen also einfach
ein rührkuchen und alles mit rein
ihr könnt jetzt aber auch einfach
trocknen lassen im backofen bei heißluft
oder in einem der automaten und dann
einfach als trockenpulver aufbewahren
können sie ins müsli noch mit rein geben
also bitte nicht wie jetzt habe ich aber
noch ein smoothie morath denn wir haben
jetzt mutig gemacht und ich würde es
gerade voll geschockt ja ich bin rote
beete mega aber du magst du immer nicht
ich habe den smoothie gekühlt weil du
immer kalte smoothies mixed deshalb
dickflüssiger und ich glaube bei kindern
kommt saft besser und bei murat immer
das gleiche ich meine es war cool aber
bei smoothies hat man halt einfach alles
im mixer ganz einfach entsafter geht
aber auch super einfach man hat halt
diese reste und reste wenn man die
weiterverwendet finde ich es ok
ansonsten finde ich es schade wenn man
das wegschmeißen würde würde ich sagen
bin ich voll gegen saft aber so als saft
finde ich es halt für kinder vor allem
gut weil es eben so
so klar ist ich mache es gleich markus
baguette brotteig und dann kommt es
einfach mit rein
ok also viel spaß beim nachmachen und
bis zum nächsten mal
[Musik]
machen jetzt einfach aus dem trester
unser brot ohne kneten da findet ihr das
rezept bereits auf dem kanal was man nur
beachten muss man braucht etwas weniger
wasser
[Musik]
ich will das jetzt aufgedeckt uns ab und
dann kommen wir unser schönes rote beete
brot ich stelle euch das rezept aber als
eigenes rezept auf dem blog
[Musik]